there can scarcely be a more stunning
backdrop for the world's most important
art exposition than Venice
many of the palazzi along the Grand
Canal or Biennale venues
the exhibition personal structures is in
the Palazzo Bembo right by the famous
rialto bridge its curator is an 88 Maya
from the Netherlands we had to find a
place somewhere in the world where the
whole art world everybody who is ever
anything to do in the world of
contemporary art comes together and
there's no other place as Venice this is
the place art has long been a byword in
Venice the theme of the personal
structures exhibition is time space and
existence 78 artists from all over the
world deal with universal issues in
their own very different ways
this installations theme is the
earthquake that devastated Christchurch
New Zealand in 2011 would say the beauty
is in the difference it is we are so
snobbish in contemporary art that we
always think that only our art our type
of art is the real kind of art but the
world is much larger than our small
region Renee leave Maya is an artist
himself he's showing a very minimalistic
work my work is nothing else than the
proof of my existence and after I die I
hope my work is still there soo Jung Min
from South Korea has created a
monumental work from thousands of pieces
of paper with Buddhist prayers written
on them his message spirituality is a
unifying force
german artist Gabi bulova is also
dealing with major issues religion and
transformation his installation is
titled the god project such an
investigation on yourself Emma and clen
class such an important exhibition is
always a magnifying glass if you have a
smaller exhibition you don't ask such
pointed questions and you don't question
your own work so precisely it's thus and
this exhibition is like a complete
distillation it helps you get to your
own essence as Ava of off sign an iron
of Sinai ignis and sukham the nooks and
crannies of the old Palazzo offer new
perspectives around every corner
this room is devoted to the fate of the
family of the last Russians are killed
in 1918 in the course of the Communist
October Revolution long a taboo subject
in Russia
the installation asks whether violence
is justified to carry out political aims
then as now a topical question yet the
sudden I certainly by fair Alice no mrs.
tell about the invitation to participate
is a thrill no still at the same time it
makes you very anxious all right you
want to do a project you think is very
important one that represents the
quintessence of your creative work and
one that can hold its own there shany at
the dock now it's dustin taking part in
this is a real accolade what reactor is
taping at emotional scars co-creator
flock and the exhibition's organizers
are celebrating the opening for three
full days in the coming months then
elite Maya will be guiding many
delegations of curators and museum
specialists through his exhibition we
expect almost a hundred thousand
visitors who will fight and debate about
the work they will have different
opinions this is good that is not good
it is a life a living confrontation
between artists and different ways of
expressing regarding the subjects time
space and existence the Biennale
marathon can begin from june fourth art
will have venice firmly in its grip what
awaits visitors is a treasure trove of
art related events spread over the
entire city
you